はい 次のスライドに行きます
現代人も自分の社会関係を明確にするべきです
例えば六法は嫌ならね
自分の社会関係を明確に考えた方がいいんです
分かりやすく言えば親がいるでしょう
伴侶がいるでしょう 師匠がいるでしょう
子孫がいるでしょう 上司がいる
仲間がいるでしょう 友人などなど
自分にいるんですね 具体的な人間がもう関わりある人間
逃げられないんですね
はい それぞれのグループに自分がどうすればいいかと
そこでよく日本で見ることが分かっているんだけど
やりたくないとかね 親が困っているようですけど
面倒見てあげたくないとか
だから私にも聞くんですね
なんかそこを抜ける方法ないのかと
そういう単語で聞いたら分かりやすい
別に言葉ごまかしてごまかして
私も忙しいんだけど 遠くにいるだけで親が田舎ですからね
まあもう仕方がないでしょうねとか
あれやこれや 結局は義務を果たしたくないという言葉なんですね
自分の存在が様々な意図で宇宙に浮いているもののようであると想像してみたらいかがでしょうかと
これは私の提案なんですね
自分という存在が宇宙にいろんな意図でぶら下がっているんですね
空中って書いて  空中に
それで糸一つ切れちゃうとヤバいんですね
だから経典によると六つの糸でぶら下がっているんです
一つでも切れちゃうと
ここでガタガタガタガタになっちゃって
その力でほかの残りの糸も切れてしまう可能性はあります
そこで不幸に陥るんです
仏教的に言えば 死後 地獄
地獄にも落ちるんですよ
いわゆる不幸に陥るんです
だから 自分が空中に浮いて浮いてるようにしてくれるこの糸をちゃんとメンテナンスをしなくちゃいけないんです
でっかい橋がありますね
あのレインボーブリッジみたいに
この何て言いますか このケーブルで吊り橋とか吊り橋
あれって電車走るわ 高速道路あるわ
一般道路があるわ 全部あのケーブルで支えているんですね
ちゃんとメンテナンスやってますよ
だから皆様に私が言いたいのは
この自分のことを空中にぶら下がっている
自分の存在は空中にぶら下がっているものであると
でも 糸で繋いでいる社会に
その糸のメンテナンスは自分がやらなくちゃいけない
社会にそんな何て言いますか
余計なことする考えないんです
この人をものすごく幸せに生かしてあげようとかね
じゃあこの人の代わりに私がこの人の親子親の面倒を見てあげようとか
それ親の面倒見たことにならないんですよ
例えば田舎のボランティア団体は年寄り
親の面倒を見ている だからといって子供が親の面倒を見たことにはならないんですよ
だから必ずしも自分がそのメンテナンスをしなくちゃいけない
自分の子供のこと 自分がもう面倒見ないで捨てちゃえば
日本社会は 日本政府はその子供を育てますよ
はい だから私はしっかり子供を育てましたと言える
それは自分の義務なの
その代わりに法律で自分は子供育児放棄したということでね
裁きますからね だからこれは自分の責任なんですね
関係の糸を切るのは自分自身ですね
だから自分自身がこの糸を切っちゃうでしょうね
切って不幸になる 不幸になって他人に文句言う
それぞれの方向 方向に適した義務責任をまず果たすんです
とにかく まず自分の義務と責任果たすんです
なんでまずそれやるんですかというと
向こうはもうとっくにやっているんです
大人になっている自分の場合は
親は責任を果たして完了しているんです
残っているのは自分のパートなんです
ですから 先に 子供の場合どうですかと
子供を作ったのは自分だから
そこで先に育てる義務が自分にあるんです
はい 次に行きます そこでエゴイストの勘違いがあるんですね
エゴイストは相手が先に義務を果たすべきだと勘違いします
例えば結婚したら男性が奥さんが全部やるべきやと
だとお前女でしょうにと
これは人間失格なんです
で これエゴイストなんです
それ当然不幸になるでしょうに
結婚したら男性にはもう義務責任生じている
女性にも義務責任が生じている
そこで文化で変な文化で女は男に尽くすべきやとかね
誰が決めたんです？そんなのは
誰も決めてない もう愚か者たちが決めたもんでしょ
ブッダが決めたわけでもないし
ソクラテスそんなこと言ったわけでもないし
プラトーン アリストテレスそんなこと言ったわけでもないし
中国のあの人 何でしたっけ
あの孔子老師言ったわけでもないし
もうアホが言ったことはよく真面目にやる
だからそうじゃなくて
人間はみんなもう対等で平等で考えなくちゃいかんですよ
結婚したら男に義務が生じる
女に義務が生じる それで誰かがそこをサボっちゃうと
そこでガタガタ関係が生まれて糸が切れるんです
切れなくてもすごく弱くなるんです
緩めちゃうんです 失敗の悩み
苦しみの原因になりますが
決して信頼される人間にはなりません
だからあなた お前の義務でお前探すやるべきでしょうと言っちゃうと
例えば子供に時々言うんですね
まあ親言うことを聞くべきです
そんな一方的に言ったら
それちょっと良くないんですね
だからそれ納得させなくちゃ
あなた方はね まだ何もわからんだから
まあ親が面倒くさいよ
守ってあげなくちゃいかんからね
ですから とにかく言うことを聞け
その方が楽ちんやと 言っちゃうと
子供たちはそれなりに理解する
それでも嫌と言ったら
では料理誰が作るの？洗濯誰がするの？じゃああんた分あなたやってくださいと
言うとできんでしょうにと
だったら私が言う通りにしなさいと
いう風に論理的に言えば
子供でもぴったし理解するんです
で 閻魔様がした人にハリセンボンなんとか言った
それ誰も聞いてもう信じてくれません
嘘を言っても で 理性のある人は自分の義務責任先に果たすんです
だから理性がある人っていうのは
まああっきり言えば仏教の人だったら
はっきり先に自分の義務を果たすんですね
あなたたちも義務を果たす
しなさいと他人に指令する指令することはやめるんです
仏教徒はやめるんです
私の義務を果たしているんだから
あなたもあなたの義務を果たしなさいと言いません
自分の義務を果たす で
相手は自由で 自分で考えて自分の義務を果たさなくちゃいけないんです
責任を果たしている自分に攻撃することはできないんです
それだけで自分の人生安定するんです
自分がしっかり義務と責任を果たしているならば
社会から何の文句も言われません
子供から親が文句言われません
上司は文句言いません
大人になった自分に両親が文句言いません
自分の義務を果たしているならば
だから そこですごい安定した自分の生き方を築くことはできるんです
なんで他人に指令することはやめるということ
そう指令する権利ないでしょ
みんな対等で平等だったら
話し合いならばいいんだけど
あなた これこれこれこれこれこれわからないんだから
私はそこら辺は教えてあげますということは
お互いの理解 納得上でいいんだけど
人は人に指令するということは論理的に成り立たないんです
自分の安らぎ 充実感を安定します
だから責任 義務を果たす人は安定して安らぎで楽しく充実感を感じながら生活できるようになります
はい ですから ブッダの言葉に行きますと
指を自分に指してみる
世界は逆なんです 人に指を指す
仏教は指を自分に指してみなさいと
ナパレサンウィローパーニナパレサンカタカタ
ちょっと意訳するんだけど
他人の間違いなどは結構ですと
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ
他人の過ち 間違い そんな調べるなよと
そんなのは結構だと 他人ナパレサンカタカタン
他人がやったこと やらなかったこと
そんなのは結構ですと
そんなことを調べれば調べるほど
気になれば気にすればするほど
自分の安らぎがなくなっているんです
自分が嫌な存在になってます
で みんなやってるんです
なんでそれはその人の自由だから別にということにしないんですかね
すごく気持ちよく生きられますよ
アッタノーハアヴェッケーヤカタニアカタニチャ
自分自身のことを観察しなさいよと
行った正しいこと 犯した間違いなどを
自分がどう生きているのかということ
何か失敗でもしたのか
何か良いことでもしたのかと言って
自分自身を自己観察し
自己観察しなさいということは
お釈迦様のこの指令 お釈迦様のアドバイスなんですね
だからそういうことは世直しはできないんです
正義の味方なんかはありえないんです
唯一できることは自分自身を正すことなんですね
はい これをやれば自分が信頼できる人間になっているんです
誰にも言う文句は残ってないんです
人に文句言うことがその人の欠点ですけど
ないんですね だから 性格最低な人でも自分のことは信頼するしかないんです
だって自分の義務を完璧に果たしているんだから
人に指差してないんだから
自分に指を差して生きているんだから
すごく尊く見えるんです
私の長い人生で このブッダの教えの通りにやっている在家の方々を見たことがあるんですよ
おじいさん おばあさんたちが
私は出家していても そういう自分のことをチェックして生きているおばあさん
おじい様方はものすごく尊く見えるんです
だから自分ももう出家もしているのに
甘えていろんなことを教えてもらったりするんです
その時すごく優しく あのね
お坊さん こういう場合はこうしましょうと
と教えてくれたりするんです
だからなんか素晴らしい関係が成り立っていたんですよ
皆様にもそれは実現できると思います
何のことなく尊い人間になってしまうんです
尊いという単語 変ですけど
信頼される人間になっているんです
はい 次に行きます そこで我々の大きな欠点が他人に期待するんです
期待すると嫌われるんです
親もそうでしょう 子供にあれやこれやと期待すると子供に嫌われるんです
だから 親子 孝行 親子 親子関係でも期待すると嫌われるならば
それは普通の法則で 心理学であって
他人に期待すると嫌われるんです
周りは正しく責任を果たして生きていることを期待する
みんなね あなたちゃんと義務を果たしている
あなた自分の義務を果たしている
あんたちゃんと責任を果たしていると指さしてしっかりやりなさいよとか言ったりする
と 大きな世話になりますよ
よく言うお節介とかね
うるさいばあちゃんとかね
言われるでしょうね 期待すると結果は自分が悩み苦しみに期待外れに陥ることです
他人に期待して期待していると
結局は自分が苦しむだけです
期待外れだったら喧嘩もしなくちゃいけないでしょう
それで信頼できる人間になるわけじゃないでしょう
自分自身が悩み苦しみに陥るだけではなくて
周りにも自分のことを嫌がりますから
そこで信頼関係がなくなるんですね
信頼できない仲間の中で信頼されない人間になってしまいます
だから 自分が期待しているその期待通りにはいかないんです
期待通りにいかないよ
これは人間の生き方 そういうことなんです
期待通りにやらない 期待しても期待した自分が悪いんです
そうすると自分が相手を信頼しない
あの人にこれこれ期待したってもやってくるんだからくれないんだから
その人は信頼できないんだと
その人も自分のことを信頼しないんです
そういう結果 信頼されない仲間の中で信頼されない人間になってしまいますね
それはやめ やめましょう
要するに 他人に期待することが良くないということなんです
相手の反応を認め 褒め
期待するのではなく 自分の責任
義務を果たす人は内面的な充実感を感じます
まあ人はいるんです 仕事をしながら
義務を果たしながら感謝してほしい
認めてほしい 褒めてほしいと
余計なことなんですね
だから一般的に人がやったことに感謝するべきなんです
人が頑張ってくれたら
それは認めるべきなんです
褒めてあげるべきなんですけど
人間やらないんだから
どうやって世直しするんですかね
一応言っておきますよ
お母さんが毎日料理作るんだったら
毎日食べる人々はそれに感謝するべきなんです
やらないんですね やらない場合は
お母さんその期待したならば
腕を振るって料理作ったんだからおいしいとか
なんか一言言ったらどうですかと
期待したらお母さんが困るんです
お母さんが精神的にストレス溜まるんです
そんなことなく 私は私の義務を果たしますと
はい よくできましたと
自分の気持ちで生活すれば充実感感じます
確実に信頼の人間 その場合は信頼されるんです
だってちゃんとやってる人だから
周りがその人のことを信頼する
はい はい 次のポイントは
人間にとっては指導しなくちゃいけない時もありますね
それでも自分が先輩指導者になったらどうしますか？と
社会組織の中で で 先輩になる
上司になる 指導者になる場合は
だから最初言ったでしょ
人にいちいち言うなよと
自分の責任を果たしてくださいと
だったら指導者にならなくなっちゃうんですね
上司にならなくなっちゃう
上司になったら部下にいろんな指令しなくちゃあかんでしょ
あ お釈迦様 あれ 坊主が言ったんだからこれダメやと
上司にならなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱりそれにはブッダの教えがあるんですね
アッターナメーパタマンパティルーペーニウェーセアタンヤマヌサーセーヤナキリセーヤパンディト
まず自分自身が正しく生きることです
いわゆる まず自分の責任
義務を果たし果たすんです
それから自分の経験も踏まえて
これは丸括弧だったのは意訳ですからね
他人に指導しても良い
だから上司になったとは部下でいたことでしょ
部下でうまくやったんだから上司になったでしょ
だからその経験を踏まえて
で こういうことで私がこうなりましたから
皆様もそうした方がいいと思いますよと
しなさいしなさいではないんですね
で 例えば給料泥棒になりません
なりなさい なってはあかんと言っちゃうと
それは侮辱ですね まあ私は昔からもう哲学があって
部下の時でも給料泥棒にはならない
自分自身で決めてたんだよと
今上司になっても給料泥棒にはなりたくない
だってこのお金で子供養ってる食べさせてるんだからね
私は合法的に正しく金儲けて
清らかに その点で清らかな生き方やってますよと
皆様も頑張っても悪くないよと一言言えば
それで聞いてくれるんです
なぜならば嘘言ってないんですね
他人に指令するのではないません
理性のある人はこのようにする
自分の心は汚れない ナキリセーヤパンディト
理性のある人は心は汚れないことに気をつけるんです
たとえ上司になっても
たとえ指導者になっても
心が汚れないように気をつける
ずっと自分の責任果たすってことはずっとあるんです
それで例えば指導者になったら偉そうなことみんなに命令して
ああしなさい こうしなさいって人の状況も考えずに
まあ恐ろしい独裁者になっちゃうと自分自身が汚れてるでしょうに
[笑い]理性のある人はこのようにする
自分の心は汚れない このようにするならば汚れない
他人に指令するのではありません
自分の経験 生き方 責任の果たし方を教えるんです
ただ 自分がこうやりました
こういう風に ブッダの教えそうでしょう
ブッダが全く指令してないんです
面白いでしょうに あれほど膨大な経典があるのに
命令形使ってないんです
あの この 我々は このオプティティブケースという動詞の形があって
提案する動詞があるんですね
そうすれば良いと そうするのだよという提案形がありまして
その動詞使ってます 例えば
殺生するなかれとお釈迦様はおっしゃってないんです
不幸になるので殺生しない方が良いと
それだけ だから 偉大なるブッダさえ
正統学者さえ否定 人に命令してないんです
なのに人間様は神様気分で他人に命令するでしょう
で やられますね それで
無視されるケース 例えば
自分が提案するする提案しても無視されるケースありますよ
だって人間バラバラだから
ケースもあり得るが ほとんどの人々はアドバイスを受けます
だから この自分がやって
その経験を生かして提案すると
だいたい九十五パーセントの人々は聞いてくれるんです
無視するのは五パーセントだけで別にいいんです
それは はい 次に行きます
[咳払い]